hi my name's Adam Horowitz I'm a PhD
student in the Media Lab in the fluid
interfaces group and I'm really happy to
be joined by Agnieszka current forecasts
three questions serious and we're gonna
be speaking through a couple projects
that Ignacio did and her visiting artist
residency and one that we did together
ignition key I do wanna start just by
introducing yourself to people hello
everyone and thank you so much to cast
for hosting this talk my name is Scott
Corum
I'm a visual artist and I was visiting
artists at MIT cast from 2016 to 2018 I
know that in past works like production
line or the end of the signature for you
automation collective intelligence and
shared authorship have been big themes
in your work and so I just thought we
could start with how those were points
of departure for your your collaboration
with Boris Katz and info group at MIT I
doing my residency at MIT I was
collaborating with csail and artificial
intelligence lab of Boris Katz and we
were working together with Boris's
fantastic a PhD and postdoc students
Andre Barbara and David Mayo on a
project that stemmed from my earlier
research and projects that I've done
before so I would like to share with you
a couple of images so I've been
interested in the phenomenon of
collective intelligence that can be
perceived in both nature and culture for
a very long time and this for example is
one of my projects where I source or
crowdsource my artworks to colonies of
living termites and together was
entomologist from
University of Florida we gave termite
colonies very vividly colored suns gold
and broken crystals and each colony
built one of these mounds so this here
what you can see as a series of works
called the end of signature where I
collect signatures of thousands of
people of various communities of social
movements of people supporting one cause
such as against climate change and a
different kind of activist groups but
also members of the workers unions and
in this serious I work each time with
computer scientists our programmer to
kind of morph aggregate together
thousands of these signatures and create
one single collective signature that
represents a kind of collective
personality of a given community this is
a facade of the Guggenheim Museum where
we collected signatures of the visitors
this is on the facade of the Cleveland
Museum of Art where these are all the
workers all the employees of this museum
as contracts workers from the members of
the board to the guards and the cleaning
ladies this is a collective signature of
all the people living in this group of
buildings in this end and this council
project the the themes with the end of
signature and production line in terms
of hybrid authorship and hybrid
production and and
materialization of a collective
intelligence um I think it's a good
segue into the animal internet project
if you could take people there perhaps
yes absolutely this is the image from
like a work in progress after of the
project done at Boris cats lab was with
his PhD and postdoc students so with
Boris we collected thousands of
self-portraits taken by workers on
Amazon Mechanical Turk and we created a
program that aggregated all these
portraits one line of pixels from
photograph to collect to create this
composite collective portrait of this
new working class then we created these
3d sculptures that were acrylic art
resin was copper and nickel plated that
were this kind of collective portraits
of this working class this was a point
of departure for our project for animal
internet animal internet it was based on
my interest in how today social energies
in society are being mined in a similar
way to oil and gas how expressions of
our joy anger frustration and 2-z asthma
Happiness are constantly being monitored
by corporations and and harvested and
how can we ourselves take advantage of
this of our own social capital and maybe
use it for other type of projects so I
looked at this phenomenon called animal
internet that was described very
interestingly in a book by Alexander
Shara that's three years ago a book of
the same title and he described this
phenomenon where people start perceiving
and nature and start being with nature
in various different ways
and for example there are animals that
have chips under their skin and they are
being tracked on animal tracker apps
around the world
there's about 150,000 of these animals
and at the same time a lot of scientific
institutes install webcams in jungles or
in the North Pole to watch completely
wild and completely unaware animals and
this broadcast are being transmitted
online and people start following these
animals these animals are being given
Facebook pages fan pages names so
there's this kind of hybrid situation of
this animals being completely wild and
unaware and meanwhile they become
celebrities online and people follow
that so in our project was Adam and our
other collaborators we used to broadcast
from two webcams with two real webcams
that you can see here one is polar bear
in the North Pole and one is
wild tiger in jungle and Thailand and we
juxtapose these two broadcasts with two
other broadcasts did we created from
scratch was was our group of artists and
engineers and so we basically created
two fictional animatronic animals one is
an animal in the upper left corner you
can see an image of in a furry animal
just wanted to say that we didn't that
all the fur used in this project was
artificial no animals were harmed so we
used this artificial fur to hide an
animatronic mechanism and we included
real plants and stones and fragments of
wood in a like a terrarium
the this animal this artificial animal
was its movements were powered by inputs
from thousands of people who were
sending us information on Amazon
Mechanical Turk about how they feel at
any given moment this were aggregated
and Adam will tell a little bit more in
that and in a couple of minutes about
the technical side of this project but
just to mention the other bottom right
corner camera this broadcast was from
the webcam that we also kind of built
from scratch in another terraria and
these are robotic animatronic gerbils
and this one of gerbils was kind of
their movement work it was powered by
well program that was parsing Twitter
feeds for a protest of members of
protest movements around the world and
this was then analyzed in an artificial
society model which is an animation
model of artificial frictional society
that our fantastic engineers wrote and
so basically this four cameras where
juxtaposing real animals and artificial
animals into one broadcast where for the
people who watch this this animals
online it doesn't
matter whether the real designate in
nature of the real animals exists
because anyway they only see their
images and I will maybe let Adam say
more about the technical side of this
project that was a content loaded and
awesome summary one piece that's that's
fun for viewers is is how we created the
project because you initially approached
us to collaborate as part of the
signature hacking hacking arts so the
the largest parts of this project was
done in 24 hours where you stayed up
with us until 3 a.m. and where we
created the robotic movements by
stripping apart a bunch of robots in
creating our own strange hybrid organism
from multiple mechanical animals and
then also where agnes coated up a sugar
scape model and then ish on was scraping
the emotion using natural language
processing from twitter to see the
intensity of emotion related to tweets
that had had the word protest in them
and that was then driving the gerbil
movement and we're then Owen was
connecting with Tim many different hex
bugs so we could make gerbils which
could communicate with each other using
radio frequency and the whole time one
thing that was really fun for me is the
discussions that we were having
we're always tied back to neuroscience
tied back to the idea of how humans are
a hybrid organism both in terms of being
cyborgs hi birds and and then also being
hybrids in terms of our collective
intelligence on the Internet changing
our own self-reflection and so one
really fun thing is the production
happening in such a hurry and the other
I think is all of the residents and
themes between the neuroscientific
aspect of it and the human-computer
interaction aspect of it and that tying
in to the themes that you're speaking
about in terms of hybrid and collective
intelligence and for me also the the
work has really continued we were
speaking about this just a few days ago
but I'm starting a new project with
support of caste and Kemet at MIT we're
again working with deconstructing
robotic animals and reconstructing them
and connecting them to humans so that
they can materialize different sorts of
changes in cognition and right now the
part
that I'm working on is a dream activated
animals project where we tie a sleep
sensor to somebody leave them in a room
but it's full of robotic animals that
we've created and when that person
enters a dream state when they
experience this sea change in cognition
all those animals will wake up and start
walking so their life only comes at the
onset of your unconsciousness but it's
really a tie between that idea of how is
it that we materialize and mechanize and
create these hybrid human robot
organisms and how is it that we can show
this energy in active form and was a
real continuation of this project and so
was just wondering also how maybe the
sugar scape model that we built or maybe
the actual collective mechanical hybrids
how many of those themes have continued
in in your work going forward if any are
still around this is absolutely
fascinating what you said Adam and I I
do believe that we will continue working
together and so yes I mean there is not
enough time here to explain all the
implications for this project but of
course this hybrid situations of like
nature culture overlap and basically
also the idea of their look at the
collapse of the of the concept of self I
mean the self is we knew it no longer
exists because it turns out that itself
is a pool if any is an aggregate of
various kinds of agencies from microbial
to algorithmic to to kind of collective
intelligence as humans being part of
society so all this has and continue to
inform my and my practice and and I want
to just briefly show you two two works
that I've recently I love is it one of
them is I think particularly interesting
because of what has happened in the
world since our project together
especially what's happened in the
world's the past couple of weeks so this
project is called collective Rorschach
test this is a lenticular print
so here you can see three different
views of the same
what it depicts it's three snapshots
from let's say a life of the of this
collective organism that was created on
the platform reddit as part of the
social experiment called place which
took place soon after our experiment was
was was adamant and and others and so
basically this experiment consisted in
over 1 million people who were who ever
wanted to join reddit platform at this
moment and this project they could put a
single pixel in a chosen color on their
white canvas so if I'm actually see the
white in the background and people
started collaborating and using using
various channels to collaborate on
various collectively built forms from
portraits of politicians that you can
see here from from Flags and like the
European Union flag Puerto Rican flag
and so on artworks here we can see a
very small fragment on the Mona Lisa -
to various kind of slogans of protest
movement and so on and at some point a
very interesting form emerged this form
was later named the black void and this
is this this black kind of and this this
form changed over time and you can see
here how its evolving and it looks like
a slime mold or a virus or another kind
of collective organism and of course
today was what's happening in the world
whenever we're looking at the pandemic
and how people are on the world are
trying to define what this pandemic is
what this virus is it itself becomes a
kind of collective Rorschach test where
everybody recognizes something else in
it and it collectively it constantly
evolves this is the second very big
project that I've been recently
developing and presenting and I will say
only a few words very briefly this
series of works called conversions and
it's directly connected to the
experiments that we have been doing with
Adam and I continued working with Agnes
Cameron on this project so this these
are paintings they are liquid crystal
paintings so it's they're executed on a
copper plate with a paint that contains
particles of liquid crystals and these
paintings are
ái paintings they are powered by the
changes in the artificial society model
and this models like in the experiments
we did together are based on constant
parsing of the protest movements Twitter
feeds members of the protest movements
whitter feet and it these changes cause
differences in artificial society model
and this in turn causes the delivery of
various electrical charges and
temperature changes to the back of this
painting so this is how the painting
changes over time you can see how it's
just few minutes later and a few minutes
later and so it oscillates between a map
a colony of bacteria
geology a slime mold and it perpetually
evolves so these are paintings that like
my earlier works are collectively
authored so the authorship is obviously
hybridized and complex but also they are
in a way mining social energies and they
always evolve they're like living
organisms and last but not least I
wanted to mention something very
important for both the works that we did
was Boris Katz and his students and also
for these works and which remains a very
important issue for me is that the
proceeds from the sales of these works
if they ever get sold is always were
distributed in the case of the works
that you're now looking at the
conversions I give back a portion of the
profits to the protest movements in the
case of the works that we did was borrow
Scott's this the process from this works
are we distributed evenly among the
workers of Amazon Mechanical Turk that
participated in it and so I'm interested
in continuing the exploration of
redistribution how our distribution of
capital can be explored with artificial
intelligence and how we can today think
about the crossover of collective
intelligence and artificial intelligence
in the arts cool.i
I think that it's almost time for us to
sign off but I just wanted to say that I
think the the project and speaking with
your
for me was a real onset of using hybrids
outside to think about hybrids inside
I'm so excited about the idea that we
are many more intelligences and we give
us credit for ourselves and we can think
about that in terms of the gut brain or
we can think about that in terms of the
intelligence and our left foot or we can
think about that in terms of biological
neural networks but this idea of your
work showing these outside hybrids
taking us and putting us in touch with
our our hybrids inside and also how that
demands that we then think about
collective authorship and redistribution
of benefits from from what it is that we
make as hybrid organisms um but I I
think it's time to sign off I just want
to give a big thank you to cast um
for this series but also for the
opportunity to collaborate with
Agnieszka which has been awesome and
will continue and that's about it thank
you so much thank you thank you thank
you I would like to give my special
thank you to Lila Kinney who was the
person who invited me to join cast Thank
You Katherine Higgins thank you everyone
thank you Adam it was a pleasure
right on thanks y'all we will thank you
all for joining us for this conversation
with technician account and Horowitz
please join us next week for big
questions with Corrine van Khalifa and
Danielle Olson and visit art stud
mit.edu from anywhere for a wide range
of art activities online exhibitions and
performances research and more have a
great weekend everyone